- [Voiceover] "On circle O
below", so this is circle O,
"segment SE is a diameter."
So this is SE, let me color that in.
So this is a diameter, that's
what they're telling us.
And they say, "What is the measure of
"angle ISE?"
So what we care about, the measure of
angle ISE.
I, S, E.
So we're trying to figure out this angle
right over there.
Now like always, I encourage
you to pause the video
and see if you can work
through it yourself.
So there's a bunch of
ways that we can actually
tackle this problem.
The first one that jumps out at me is
there's a bunch of
triangles here, and we can
use the fact that the
angles, interior angles
of a triangle add up to 180 degrees.
So we could look at this
triangle right over here.
And so we know one of the angles already.
We know this angle has a
measurement of 27 degrees.
If we could figure out
this angle right over here,
this would be angle
SIE, then if we know two
interior angles of a triangle, we can
figure out the third.
And this one, SIE, we can figure it out
because it's supplementary
to this 61-degree angle.
So this angle right over
here is just going to be
this angle plus the 61-degree angle
is going to be equal to 180 degrees,
because they are supplementary.
Or we could say that this angle over here
is going to be 180 minus 61.
So what is that going to be?
180 minus 60 would be 120,
and then minus one gives us 119.
119 degrees.
And so this angle that we
are trying to figure out,
this angle plus the 119 degrees, plus
the 27 degrees, is going to be equal to
180 degrees.
Or we could say this angle is going to be
180 minus 119,
minus 27.
Which is going to be equal to,
so let's see, 180 minus 119
is 61.
And then 61 minus 27
is going to be 34.
So there you have it.
The measure of angle ISE is 34 degrees.
Now I mentioned that
there is multiple ways
that we could figure this out.
Let me do it one more way.
So let me unwind everything that I
just wrote.
We already figured out the answer,
but I want to show you that there's
multiple ways that we can tackle this.
So ISE is still the thing that we
want to figure out.
Another way that we could approach it
is we know we have some angles
inscribed angles on this circle,
and we know that if an inscribed angle
intercepts a diameter,
then it's going to be
a right angle.
It's going to be a 90 degree angle.
So this angle right over here is
a 90 degree angle.
And we can use that information to
figure out this angle,
and we can also use that information
if we look at this triangle,
we could use 90 plus 61 plus this angle
is going to be equal to 180 degrees.
So this angle right over here, another way
to think about it, it's
going to be 180 minus 90
minus 61.
Which is equal to, 180 minus 90 is 90,
minus 61 is 29 degrees.
So this one right over here is 29 degrees.
And then we could look
at this larger triangle.
To figure out this entire angle.
If we know this entire
angle, you subtract 29
then you figure out angle ISE.
And so this large, or what I've depicted,
this kind of magenta
measure right over here
of that angle, plus 90 degrees,
plus 27 degrees, is
going to be equal to 180
because they're the interior
angles of triangle SLE.
So this angle right
over here is going to be
180 minus 61
minus 27.
Sorry, not minus 61, minus 90.
It's 180 minus 90, minus 27
is going to give us this
angle right over here
because the three angles add up to 180.
So minus 90, minus 27.
Which is equal to, so 180 minus 90 is 90.
90 minus 27
is 63.
63 degrees.
So this large one over here is 63 degrees,
and then the smaller one is 29 degrees.
And so angle ISE, which
we set out to figure out,
is going to be 63 degrees
minus the 29 degrees.
So 63 minus 29 is once again
equal to 34 degrees.
So the way I did it just
now, a little bit harder.
It really depends what jumps out at you.
The first way I tackled it,
it does seem a little bit
easier, a little bit clearer.
But it's good to see
these different things.
And at least here, we used this idea
of an inscribed angle that
intercepts a diameter.
And if you say, "Hey, how do we know?"
Well, we've proven in other videos,
but it comes straight out of the idea that
the measure of an inscribed angle
is going to be half of
the measure of the arc
that it intercepts.
And notice, it's intercepting an arc
that has a measure of 180 degrees.
It's intercepting an arc that has
a measure of 180 degrees.
And so this angle's
going to be half of that
since it's an inscribed
angle, not a central angle.
So it's going to be a 90 degree angle.